Put a spring in your step with SiriusXM. In Bakersfield, California in 1991, two boys stumbled upon a grisly discovery, the murdered body of a young woman. In the Shadows is the new podcast from Casefire Presents, which follows the ensuing 32-year ordeal to uncover those responsible for the crime and to bring them to justice. The mystery riveted the desert town for years. Police immediately zeroed in on the victim's longtime boyfriend, a beloved star athlete. But popular opinion was divided. Despite national attention and several trials, a conviction remained elusive and many thought the case would never be solved. That is, until this podcast turned over a new leaf.
通过SiriusXM让你的生活充满活力。1991年，在加利福尼亚州贝克斯菲尔德，两名男孩偶然发现了一具令人毛骨悚然的尸体，那是一名年轻女性的遗体。《In the Shadows》是Casefire Presents推出的全新播客，讲述了随后的32年里，人们为查明罪魁祸首并将其绳之以法所经历的磨难。这起悬案多年来一直困扰着这座沙漠小镇。警方最初将目光锁定在受害者交往多年的男友身上，他是一位备受爱戴的明星运动员。但公众舆论却出现了分歧。尽管受到全国关注并进行了多次审判，但定罪依然遥遥无期，许多人认为这起案件永远无法侦破。直到这档播客翻开了新的一页。
During the investigation of In the Shadows, several individuals revealed shocking information previously unknown to authorities. Ultimately, this new insight turned everything on its head and will bring you one step closer to deciding who's responsible for the murder. Previously only available with the Wondery Plus subscription, all seven episodes of In the Shadows are now available for free wherever you get your podcasts, or you can listen ad-free on Wondery Plus. Stay tuned to hear the trailer at the end of today's episode. Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support and for a more detailed list of content warnings, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. When the winning numbers of the Florida Lottery were announced on Wednesday, October 25, 2006, the $3 million jackpot went unclaimed.
在《In the Shadows》的调查过程中，几个人透露了此前不为当局所知的惊人信息。最终，这些新见解颠覆了一切，并将让你离确定谁该为这起谋杀案负责更近一步。此前仅限Wondery Plus订阅用户收听的《In the Shadows》全部七集，现在可以在你获取播客的任何地方免费收听，或者在Wondery Plus上免广告收听。请继续收听本集结尾的预告片。我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果你在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码以及更详细的内容警告列表，请查看你应用内或我们网站上的本集节目说明。当佛罗里达州彩票的中奖号码在2006年10月25日星期三公布时，300万美元的头奖无人认领。
This wasn't unusual. The odds of picking the six lucky numbers from a possible 69 was one in over $292 million. With no claimants, the Florida Lottery jackpot rolled over, meaning it was added to the grand prize of the next draw. Once again, nobody won. Over the following two weeks, the jackpot rolled over three more times. By Wednesday, November 15, 2006, it had reached $30 million. The small home he shared with his mother was in the same underprivileged neighbourhood where Abraham had spent most of his life. Despite experiencing poverty, homelessness, discrimination and run-ins with the law, Abraham remained good-natured.
这并不罕见。从69个数字中选出6个幸运数字的概率是2.92亿分之一。由于无人认领，佛罗里达州彩票的头奖进行了滚存，这意味着它被加到了下一次开奖的奖金池中。结果还是没人中奖。在接下来的两周里，头奖又滚存了三次。到2006年11月15日星期三，奖金已达到3000万美元。他与母亲合住的小房子位于亚伯拉罕度过大半生的同一个贫困社区。尽管经历了贫困、无家可归、歧视和与法律的冲突，亚伯拉罕依然保持着善良的本性。
The small home he shared with his mother was in the same underprivileged neighbourhood where Abraham had spent most of his life. Despite having run-ins with the law, Abraham remained good-natured and easygoing. Even though he mostly kept to himself, he was a familiar and well-liked figure in his community. Abraham had no bank account, credit card or savings. Dropping out of school in the seventh grade had left him with few skills or opportunities. The labor pool, a network of independent workers that could be hired on an as-needed basis for various jobs. The tall and slender African-American took on any work available, from washing dishes and sweeping floors to collecting trash and loading trucks. Although he spent most of his time working, Abraham Shakespeare constantly scraped the breadline.
他与母亲合住的小房子位于亚伯拉罕度过大半生的同一个贫困社区。尽管曾与法律发生过冲突，亚伯拉罕依然保持着善良和随和的性格。尽管他大多独来独往，但他却是社区里一个熟悉且受欢迎的人物。亚伯拉罕没有银行账户、信用卡或储蓄。七年级辍学使他几乎没有掌握什么技能或机会。劳动力库是一个由独立工人组成的网络，可以按需雇佣来从事各种工作。这位身材高大、体型瘦削的非裔美国人承担了所有能找到的工作，从洗碗、扫地到收集垃圾和装卸卡车。尽管他大部分时间都在工作，但亚伯拉罕·莎士比亚始终在贫困线上挣扎。
In 2006, he was earning just $8 an hour as a truck driver's assistant for a food distribution company. Despite his best efforts, he'd fallen behind on paying child support for his five-year-old son. In his rare moments of respite, Abraham would walk around Lake Hollingsworth in the city centre. He'd imagine owning one of the expensive houses that overlooked the water, only to reflect on his current circumstances with disappointment. On Wednesday, November 15, 2006, Abraham and a colleague named Michael Ford set out on a 230-mile route to deliver meat to fast-food restaurants. Not long after leaving Lakeland, the pair stopped at a convenience store in the city of Frostproof. Michael headed inside to buy drinks and cigarettes, asking Abraham if he wanted a soda. Abraham instead told Michael to, quote, get me two quick picks.
2006年，他作为一家食品配送公司的卡车司机助理，时薪仅为8美元。尽管他尽了最大努力，但他还是拖欠了五岁儿子的抚养费。在难得的休息时间里，亚伯拉罕会绕着市中心的霍林斯沃思湖散步。他会想象自己拥有那些俯瞰湖水的昂贵住宅，但随后又会失望地反思自己的现状。2006年11月15日星期三，亚伯拉罕和一位名叫迈克尔·福特的同事出发前往一条230英里的路线，为快餐店运送肉类。离开莱克兰不久，两人在弗罗斯特普鲁夫市的一家便利店停了下来。迈克尔进去买饮料和香烟，问亚伯拉罕要不要汽水。亚伯拉罕却告诉迈克尔，引用他的话说，“给我买两张快选票”。
Quick picks are a type of lottery ticket. The player's six numbers are randomly generated in the lottery terminal and added to their coupon. Compared to the more traditional method where a player personally selects each number, it's a fast and easy way to play the lottery. Michael Ford purchased two quick picks for Abraham, and Abraham paid him two of the five dollars he currently had to his name. He gave the remaining three dollars to a homeless man. The Florida Lotto was drawn that night. The numbers announced were 6, 12, 13, 34, 42, and 52. Abraham Shakespeare was stunned. He had just won $30 million. Abraham appeared on television to celebrate his massive lottery win. He was his typical laid-back self, dressed in baggy pants and a white t-shirt with his dreadlocks tucked under his cap.
快选票是一种彩票。玩家的六个数字由彩票终端随机生成并添加到他们的彩票上。与玩家亲自选择每个数字的传统方式相比，这是一种快速且简单的彩票玩法。迈克尔·福特为亚伯拉罕购买了两张快选票，亚伯拉罕用他当时仅有的五美元中的两美元支付了费用。他把剩下的三美元给了路边的一名流浪汉。当晚佛罗里达州彩票开奖。公布的号码是6、12、13、34、42和52。亚伯拉罕·莎士比亚惊呆了。他刚刚赢得了3000万美元。亚伯拉罕出现在电视上庆祝他赢得的巨额彩票。他表现得一如既往地随性，穿着宽松的裤子和一件白色T恤，脏辫塞在帽子下面。
Abraham was handed an oversized novelty check with $30 million printed on it in large, bold lettering. He had two options. Received the prize money in annual increments of $1.5 million over 20 years, or taken immediate lump sum minus 25% in taxes. Abraham chose the second option, as most lottery winners do, and walked away with $17 million. For Abraham, who'd only ever known poverty, that was more than enough. As he collected his winnings, he announced, I don't have to struggle no more. Abraham immediately used his newfound wealth to resolve several debts, including the child support he owed. He also set up a million dollar trust for his son. Although lottery winners are advised to seek the services of a financial advisor, Abraham didn't believe he needed one, saying, I don't let material things run me. I'm on a tight budget.
亚伯拉罕拿到了一张印有3000万美元字样的超大号纪念支票。他有两个选择：在20年内每年分期领取150万美元的奖金，或者一次性领取扣除25%税款后的现金。亚伯拉罕像大多数彩票中奖者一样选择了第二种方案，最终拿到了1700万美元。对于只经历过贫困的亚伯拉罕来说，这已经绰绰有余了。在领取奖金时，他宣布：“我再也不用挣扎了。”亚伯拉罕立即用他新获得的财富偿还了几笔债务，包括他拖欠的抚养费。他还为儿子设立了一个百万美元的信托基金。尽管彩票中奖者被建议寻求财务顾问的服务，但亚伯拉罕认为他不需要，他说：“我不会让物质支配我。我的预算很紧。”
Despite being a multi-millionaire, Abraham continued to eat at his local Denny's Diner, pick up pennies off the ground, and spend his days hanging out in his old neighborhood. Abraham offered to buy his mother a new home, but she respectfully declined, so he paid off her existing house instead. He then established several philanthropic enterprises that centered on assisting those in need. Abraham rewarded himself with just a few splurges, including a new car, some clothes, and a Rolex watch that he bought at a discount from a pawn shop. His biggest indulgence was a million dollar home north of the city in an upscale gated community on Redhawk Bend Drive. The spacious two-story residence had four bedrooms and four bathrooms. It featured stainless steel appliances, granite counters, walk-in closets, fireplaces, a guest suite, and a double garage. French doors opened out to a private deck with a swimming pool and spa.
尽管已是千万富翁，亚伯拉罕仍继续在当地的丹尼餐厅吃饭，捡地上的硬币，并花时间在旧社区闲逛。亚伯拉罕提出要给母亲买一套新房子，但她礼貌地拒绝了，于是他付清了她现有房子的贷款。随后，他建立了几家旨在帮助有需要的人的慈善企业。亚伯拉罕只给自己买了几样奢侈品，包括一辆新车、一些衣服，以及他在当铺打折买的一块劳力士手表。他最大的挥霍是在城北一个高档封闭式社区的红鹰弯道买下了一栋价值百万美元的房子。这栋宽敞的两层住宅有四间卧室和四间浴室。它配有不锈钢电器、花岗岩台面、步入式衣橱、壁炉、客房套房和双车库。法式门通向一个带有游泳池和水疗中心的私人露台。
It was exactly the type of home Abraham had dreamed of owning. Although Abraham's money didn't change him much, it changed everyone around him. As soon as news of his big win got out, friends and strangers alike began approaching him with stories of financial hardship. Described as a soft touch who thought with his heart, Abraham willingly helped them pay everything from bills to medical treatments and business startups. He lost count of how many people he helped, saying, the Bible states it's better to give than to receive. In Abraham's eyes, most of these handouts were loans rather than gifts. Yet no one ever made any effort to pay him back. Questions about when Abraham's generosity would be repaid were met with excuses and complaints.
这正是亚伯拉罕梦想拥有的那种房子。虽然亚伯拉罕的钱并没有改变他多少，但却改变了他周围的所有人。他中大奖的消息一传出，朋友和陌生人就开始带着经济困难的故事找上门来。亚伯拉罕被描述为一个心肠软、容易动情的人，他乐意帮助他们支付从账单到医疗费和创业资金的一切费用。他记不清自己帮助了多少人，他说：“圣经上说，施比受更有福。”在亚伯拉罕看来，这些施舍大多是贷款而不是赠予。然而，从来没有人试图还钱给他。当被问及亚伯拉罕的慷慨何时能得到回报时，人们总是以各种借口和抱怨来搪塞。
Some people were upset to learn his money was given with strings attached. Conflict also arose in Abraham's family over the amount he shared with them. Rather than making him happy, Abraham said his lottery win had made him miserable. People constantly stopped him in the street and his cell phone rang non-stop. During a 30 minute catch up with his younger brother, Abraham fielded eight calls from people requesting cash. He even received a letter from a prison inmate asking for $1,000. While this request amused Abraham, he still sent the man $50. Abraham's sister said he was too sweet-natured to say no to anybody, and because of his limitless charity, Abraham never had any peace.
有些人得知他的钱是有附加条件的，对此感到不满。亚伯拉罕的家人也因为他分享的金额而产生了冲突。亚伯拉罕说，中彩票并没有让他感到快乐，反而让他痛苦不堪。人们不断在街上拦住他，他的手机也响个不停。在与弟弟进行的一次30分钟的通话中，亚伯拉罕接到了八个请求现金的电话。他甚至收到了一名监狱囚犯的来信，要求他提供1000美元。虽然这个请求让亚伯拉罕觉得好笑，但他还是寄给了那个人50美元。亚伯拉罕的姐姐说，他性格太好，不懂得拒绝任何人，也因为他无底线的慈善，亚伯拉罕从未得到过安宁。
Both exasperated by his instant celebrity and demoralized by everyone's demands, he began sleeping all day and cruising the quiet streets of Lakeland at night. Abraham also escaped by traveling. He went on a cruise to the Caribbean and took a few short trips to New York City, which he grew particularly fond of. He hoped the distance from his community would lessen the pressure, expectations and hostilities thrust upon him. Michael Ford was bitter towards his former colleague Abraham Shakespeare. Michael frequently visited the Frostproof convenience store where the winning lottery ticket was purchased. Without fail, he always bought two quick picks for himself. Michael asserted that Wednesday, November 16, 2006, was no different.
由于对突如其来的名气感到恼火，又被众人的要求弄得心力交瘁，他开始整天睡觉，晚上在莱克兰安静的街道上开车兜风。亚伯拉罕也通过旅行来逃避。他去加勒比海游轮旅行，并去纽约市进行了几次短途旅行，他特别喜欢那里。他希望远离社区能减轻施加在他身上的压力、期望和敌意。迈克尔·福特对他的前同事亚伯拉罕·莎士比亚怀恨在心。迈克尔经常光顾购买中奖彩票的那家弗罗斯特普鲁夫便利店。毫无例外，他总是给自己买两张快选票。迈克尔坚称，2006年11月16日星期三也不例外。
Store records and CCTV footage confirmed that Michael had purchased two quick picks that day. Michael insisted that if he had purchased any for Abraham Shakespeare, then he would have had four tickets in total. According to Michael, he tucked the tickets into his wallet, which he kept in an overhead compartment inside his truck. Michael said he realized his lottery tickets were missing the following day. He assumed that he'd lost them until a supervisor informed him that Abraham won the jackpot. Michael confronted Abraham and accused him of stealing the tickets while he'd been left alone in the truck. Abraham allegedly admitted to swiping the tickets from Michael's wallet and was confident that no one could prove it. Michael said Abraham had offered him a million dollars to put the matter to rest, but he'd decided to file a lawsuit against Abraham instead.
商店记录和闭路电视录像证实，迈克尔那天确实购买了两张快选票。迈克尔坚持认为，如果他为亚伯拉罕·莎士比亚买了彩票，那么他总共应该有四张票。据迈克尔说，他把票塞进了钱包，放在卡车里的头顶储物格中。迈克尔说，第二天他发现彩票不见了。他以为自己弄丢了，直到主管告诉他亚伯拉罕中了头奖。迈克尔与亚伯拉罕对质，指责他在自己独自留在卡车里时偷走了彩票。据称，亚伯拉罕承认从迈克尔的钱包里偷走了彩票，并确信没有人能证明这一点。迈克尔说，亚伯拉罕曾提出给他一百万美元来平息此事，但他决定起诉亚伯拉罕。
Abraham flatly denied these allegations, saying, Michael Ford knows the truth. I know the truth. The Lord knows he doesn't deserve it. It's like a dirty money. That money wasn't meant for him. It was meant for me. According to Abraham, after his win, Michael asked Abraham to look out for him by giving him a million dollars so he could move into state and start a business. Abraham was willing to help, but lottery officials hadn't wired him the money yet, so he told Michael to be patient. He also offered a smaller amount as he felt a million dollars was excessive. Michael confronted Abraham again two days later, this time indicating his intention to sue. Abraham explained,
亚伯拉罕断然否认了这些指控，他说：“迈克尔·福特知道真相。我知道真相。上帝知道他不配得到这笔钱。这就像是不义之财。那笔钱本来就不属于他。它是属于我的。”据亚伯拉罕说，中奖后，迈克尔要求亚伯拉罕给他一百万美元，以便他能搬到外州创业。亚伯拉罕愿意帮忙，但彩票官员还没有把钱汇给他，所以他告诉迈克尔要耐心等待。他还提出给一笔较小的金额，因为他觉得一百万美元太多了。两天后，迈克尔再次与亚伯拉罕对质，这次表示了他起诉的意图。亚伯拉罕解释说：
When Michael brought up the word court, I backed away from him. I told him I don't owe him nothing. I told him if you feel like you have a case, go on to court. By the time Michael came for Abraham's prize money, there was 12 million dollars left. Michael sought injunctive relief, which would immediately freeze Abraham's assets and prevent him from spending any more of the winnings. A circuit court judge ruled in Michael's favor. The matter went to court in October 2007, five months after Abraham's big win. The dramatic proceedings became a public spectacle. Michael Ford's attorney worked to undermine Abraham's character by repeatedly bringing up his criminal past. At age 13, Abraham was caught stealing from a convenience store and sent to a state-run juvenile reform school.
“当迈克尔提到‘法庭’这个词时，我退缩了。我告诉他我不欠他任何东西。我告诉他，如果你觉得你有理，那就去法庭吧。”当迈克尔来索要亚伯拉罕的奖金时，还剩下1200万美元。迈克尔寻求禁令救济，这将立即冻结亚伯拉罕的资产，并阻止他继续花费奖金。巡回法院法官做出了有利于迈克尔的裁决。此事于2007年10月进入法庭，距离亚伯拉罕中大奖仅五个月。戏剧性的诉讼过程成为了公众关注的焦点。迈克尔·福特的律师通过反复提及亚伯拉罕的犯罪前科来诋毁他的人格。13岁时，亚伯拉罕因在便利店行窃被捕，并被送往州立少年管教所。
He remained there until he was 18, then proceeded to rack up a range of offenses that included trespassing, assault, and theft. As an adult, he amassed seven felony and three misdemeanor convictions, resulting in two stints in prison. Michael Ford's attorney asked the court, does a leopard change its spots? When witnesses attested to Abraham's good character, Michael's counsel accused Abraham of paying them off for their testimony. In turn, Abraham's attorney accused the plaintiff of piling dirt on his client, saying that bringing up his criminal record was an attempt to distract the jury from the pertinent issues. They questioned why Abraham would steal the lottery tickets, which were worthless at the time the alleged theft occurred. Abraham had no way of knowing one would win the jackpot. Abraham also had an extensive history of playing the lottery.
他在那里一直待到18岁，随后又犯下了一系列罪行，包括非法入侵、袭击和盗窃。作为成年人，他累计有七项重罪和三项轻罪定罪，导致两次入狱。迈克尔·福特的律师问法庭：“豹子能改变身上的斑点吗？”当证人证明亚伯拉罕品行良好时，迈克尔的律师指责亚伯拉罕花钱收买他们作证。反过来，亚伯拉罕的律师指责原告往他的当事人身上泼脏水，称提及他的犯罪记录是试图分散陪审团对相关问题的注意力。他们质疑亚伯拉罕为什么要偷彩票，因为在所谓的盗窃发生时，这些彩票一文不值。亚伯拉罕根本无法预知哪一张会中头奖。亚伯拉罕也有长期购买彩票的历史。
To prove it, he carried a garbage bag into court stuffed with tickets he had purchased over the years. Michael was revealed to be a liar. In sworn testimony as part of the pre-trial discovery process, Michael said he'd lent Abraham money in the past to help put food on his table. But during the trial, Michael denied ever helping Abraham at all. After five days of testimony and a little over an hour's deliberation, the jury unanimously agreed that Abraham Shakespeare did not steal the lottery tickets from Michael Ford. Michael was denied any of Abraham's winnings. Abraham's lawyer told the media, This lawsuit was about greed.
为了证明这一点，他带了一个垃圾袋到法庭，里面装满了多年来购买的彩票。迈克尔被揭穿是个骗子。在审前取证过程中的宣誓证词中，迈克尔说他过去曾借钱给亚伯拉罕以帮助他维持生计。但在审判期间，迈克尔否认曾帮助过亚伯拉罕。经过五天的证词和略多于一小时的审议，陪审团一致同意亚伯拉罕·莎士比亚没有从迈克尔·福特那里偷走彩票。迈克尔被驳回了对亚伯拉罕奖金的任何索求。亚伯拉罕的律师告诉媒体：“这场诉讼是关于贪婪的。”
The plaintiff manufactured a story and a plan to try to take advantage of my client. While Abraham felt Michael had scandalized his reputation, he ultimately forgave him. He didn't harbor any anger, saying, That guy used to be a real good friend of mine. If he only waited, I could have given him $250,000 easy. Michael rejected the jury's findings and began a lengthy appeals process. The final hearing was scheduled for Wednesday, May 27, 2009, two and a half years after Abraham won the lottery. Michael Ford's appeal was ultimately dismissed, but Abraham Shakespeare wasn't around to hear the good news.
“原告编造了一个故事和计划，试图利用我的当事人。”虽然亚伯拉罕觉得迈克尔损害了他的名誉，但他最终原谅了他。他没有怀恨在心，说：“那家伙曾经是我一个很好的朋友。如果他再等等，我本来可以轻松给他25万美元的。”迈克尔拒绝接受陪审团的裁决，并开始了漫长的上诉程序。最终听证会定于2009年5月27日星期三举行，即亚伯拉罕中彩票两年半后。迈克尔·福特的上诉最终被驳回，但亚伯拉罕·莎士比亚并没有出现来听这个好消息。
No one had seen Abraham in the weeks leading up to the hearing and calls to his cell phone were going unanswered. Words spread that he'd skipped town to avoid the spotlight and get some much needed rest. Since his lottery win, Abraham had become a father for the second time. He'd separated from the baby's mother shortly after the birth and the pair had been embroiled in hostile court proceedings ever since. There was gossip that the woman had intentionally become pregnant just to access Abraham's money. This fueled a belief that he'd fled to avoid paying child support. He also had an unpaid bill with the law firm that fought his civil suit. The rumor mill swung into overdrive.
在听证会前的几周里，没有人见过亚伯拉罕，打给他的手机也无人接听。有传言说他为了避开聚光灯并获得急需的休息而离开了小镇。自中彩票以来，亚伯拉罕第二次当了父亲。他在孩子出生后不久就与孩子母亲分开了，两人此后一直陷入敌对的法庭诉讼中。有流言称，那个女人故意怀孕只是为了得到亚伯拉罕的钱。这助长了一种信念，即他为了逃避支付抚养费而逃跑了。他还拖欠了为他打民事诉讼的律师事务所的费用。谣言四起。
Some claimed Abraham was doing business or receiving medical treatment overseas. Others accused him of being on the run from police. Those who knew Abraham best denied these assertions. There were even rumors that he'd died of AIDS despite some alleged sightings of him around Lakeland. Prior to winning the lottery, Abraham spent several days a week doing odd jobs at a barbershop owned by his longtime friend Greg Smith. Greg saw firsthand the overwhelmingly negative impact that the win had on Abraham. His sonny disposition faded and he often told Greg, I wish I could go back to my old self.
有人声称亚伯拉罕在海外做生意或接受治疗。其他人则指责他在躲避警察。那些最了解亚伯拉罕的人否认了这些说法。甚至有传言说他死于艾滋病，尽管有人声称在莱克兰附近见过他。在赢得彩票之前，亚伯拉罕每周花几天时间在他长期朋友格雷格·史密斯拥有的理发店打零工。格雷格亲眼目睹了中奖对亚伯拉罕造成的压倒性的负面影响。他阳光的性格消失了，他经常对格雷格说：“我真希望我能回到以前的自己。”
Greg had been struggling to stay on top of his mortgage repayments but he'd kept this from Abraham as he didn't want to be seen as another moocher. One day, Abraham spotted banking documents at Greg's barbershop. Realising his friend was in trouble, he paid off Greg's $63,000 mortgage. Greg agreed to give Abraham $500 a month until the debt was repaid. When Abraham abruptly left Lakeland and stopped answering his phone, Greg sent him a text message that read, call me, it's important. Abraham messaged back, Bro, I'm on a cruise and I'll be back in town soon, I just needed to get away because all these people are bothering me about money.
格雷格一直在努力偿还抵押贷款，但他对亚伯拉罕隐瞒了这一点，因为他不想被视为另一个寄生虫。一天，亚伯拉罕在格雷格的理发店发现了银行文件。意识到朋友有困难，他付清了格雷格6.3万美元的抵押贷款。格雷格同意每月给亚伯拉罕500美元，直到债务还清。当亚伯拉罕突然离开莱克兰并停止接听电话时，格雷格给他发了一条短信，写道：“给我回电话，这很重要。”亚伯拉罕回信说：“兄弟，我在游轮上，很快就会回城，我只是需要离开一下，因为所有这些人都在为钱的事烦我。”
Greg told Abraham to call him immediately. Abraham replied, I'll call you in the morning, I'm just trying to get myself together. Greg was struck by the exchange. Abraham's limited education meant he struggled to read and write. He preferred calling or speaking with people face to face over communicating through text. Abraham's messages were also unusually formal. They didn't reflect his usual speech and writing patterns.
格雷格告诉亚伯拉罕立即给他回电话。亚伯拉罕回答说：“我早上会给你打电话，我只是在努力调整自己。”格雷格对这次交流感到震惊。亚伯拉罕受教育程度有限，这意味着他很难读写。他更喜欢打电话或与人面对面交谈，而不是通过短信交流。亚伯拉罕的短信也异常正式。它们没有反映出他平时的说话和写作习惯。
Greg's wife agreed that the messages were odd. She sent Abraham a text asking him to come home. He replied, I'll be home soon and I'll call you when I get back. Days passed but Abraham didn't call. Abraham was a doting father who typically called his elder son twice a week. These calls also stopped and were replaced by text messages. He sent one acquaintance upwards of 60 texts but still made no calls.
格雷格的妻子也认为这些短信很奇怪。她给亚伯拉罕发了一条短信，请他回家。他回答说：“我很快就会回家，回来后我会给你打电话。”几天过去了，但亚伯拉罕没有打电话。亚伯拉罕是一位慈爱的父亲，通常每周给大儿子打两次电话。这些电话也停止了，取而代之的是短信。他给一个熟人发了60多条短信，但仍然没有打过一个电话。
In his messages, Abraham assured everyone that he was fine and okay. During one exchange, he was uncharacteristically belligerent, referring to himself as a grown-ass man who would return to Lakeland when he was ready. Increasingly suspicious, one of Abraham's associates texted a question that only he could answer. There was no response. A few people tried to report Abraham missing but were dismissed because they weren't family. Abraham's mother, Elizabeth, considered doing so as Abraham wasn't the type to go away for long periods without getting in touch. But one of her nephews, Cedric Adam, said that Abraham was calling him daily.
在短信中，亚伯拉罕向所有人保证他很好，没事。在一次交流中，他表现得异常好斗，称自己是一个成年男人，准备好后就会回到莱克兰。越来越怀疑的亚伯拉罕的一位同事发了一条只有他能回答的问题。没有回应。几个人试图报告亚伯拉罕失踪，但因为他们不是家人而被驳回。亚伯拉罕的母亲伊丽莎白考虑这样做，因为亚伯拉罕不是那种在不联系的情况下长时间离开的人。但她的一个侄子塞德里克·亚当说，亚伯拉罕每天都在给他打电话。
He had also received a birthday card for Elizabeth from Abraham. Elizabeth contained $100 and a necklace along with a handwritten message that read, I'll be home soon, followed by Abraham's signature. Elizabeth recognized her son's handwriting which temporarily quashed any niggling concerns. By November, seven months had passed since Abraham left Lakeland. Thanksgiving was one of his favorite holidays. When the day came and went without any word, Abraham's prolonged silence became too loud to ignore. Abraham Shakespeare was officially reported missing.
他还收到了亚伯拉罕寄给伊丽莎白的生日贺卡。里面有100美元和一条项链，还有一张手写的纸条，上面写着：“我很快就会回家”，后面是亚伯拉罕的签名。伊丽莎白认出了儿子的笔迹，这暂时平息了她内心细微的担忧。到了11月，亚伯拉罕离开莱克兰已经七个月了。感恩节是他最喜欢的节日之一。当这一天过去而没有任何消息时，亚伯拉罕长期的沉默变得令人无法忽视。亚伯拉罕·莎士比亚被正式报告失踪。
Finding him wasn't going to be easy. Abraham was accustomed to living a transient lifestyle. When he left Lakeland, Abraham was dating a woman named Courtney Daniels. Courtney told police the last time she'd seen Abraham was the first week of April. He'd dropped her at a bus station so she could visit a friend interstate. That night, the couple spoke on the phone for hours, but after that, Courtney never heard another word. She soon learned of a rumor that Abraham had left Florida with another woman. When she returned to Abraham's house to pack up her things, all of his belongings were still there.
找到他并不容易。亚伯拉罕习惯于过着漂泊的生活。当他离开莱克兰时，亚伯拉罕正在和一位名叫考特尼·丹尼尔斯的女性约会。考特尼告诉警方，她最后一次见到亚伯拉罕是在4月的第一周。他把她送到汽车站，以便她能去外州探望朋友。那天晚上，两人在电话里聊了几个小时，但那之后，考特尼再也没有收到任何消息。她很快得知了一个传言，说亚伯拉罕和另一个女人离开了佛罗里达。当她回到亚伯拉罕的房子收拾东西时，他所有的财物都还在那里。
After winning the lottery, Abraham grew tired of all the paperwork and meetings related to his finances. He'd sought help from a friend of 15 years, Judy Hagens, who assumed the unofficial role of his assistant. Abraham eventually designated Judy as his power of attorney. This meant she had control over all of his financial decisions and could handle his affairs whenever he went away. Others viewed this decision as absurd. Judy had no business or legal qualifications and was viewed by some as a party girl. Regardless, Abraham signed the papers in early April of 2009, shortly before he disappeared. Judy told police she hadn't seen him since.
赢得彩票后，亚伯拉罕厌倦了所有与财务相关的文书工作和会议。他向15年的朋友朱迪·哈根斯寻求帮助，后者承担了他助理的非正式角色。亚伯拉罕最终指定朱迪为他的授权委托人。这意味着她可以控制他所有的财务决策，并在他离开时处理他的事务。其他人认为这个决定很荒谬。朱迪没有任何商业或法律资格，被一些人视为一个爱玩的人。无论如何，亚伯拉罕在2009年4月初签署了文件，就在他失踪前不久。朱迪告诉警方，从那以后她就没见过他。
Abraham had been scheduled to appear in court in August for a child support enforcement action, but never showed up. His attorney, Howard Stitzel, told the court that Abraham was out of the country receiving medical treatment for an undisclosed illness. When questioned by police, Howard said the last time he'd spoken to Abraham on the phone was in October, almost six months since he'd last been seen in Florida. He was reluctant to divulge the specifics due to attorney-client privilege, but was absolutely certain it was Abraham he'd spoken to as he was familiar with his voice. Abraham hadn't sounded distressed and there had been no follow-ups. Due to the conflicting rumors regarding his whereabouts, police weren't sure what to make of Abraham Shakespeare's disappearance.
亚伯拉罕原定于8月出庭参加一项抚养费执行行动，但从未露面。他的律师霍华德·斯蒂策尔告诉法庭，亚伯拉罕在国外接受一种未公开疾病的治疗。当被警方询问时，霍华德说他最后一次在电话里与亚伯拉罕交谈是在10月，距离他最后一次在佛罗里达被看到已经过去了近六个月。由于律师与客户的特权，他不愿透露具体细节，但绝对肯定他通话的对象是亚伯拉罕，因为他熟悉他的声音。亚伯拉罕听起来并不痛苦，也没有后续联系。由于关于他下落的传言相互矛盾，警方不确定该如何看待亚伯拉罕·莎士比亚的失踪。
They accepted the possibility that he was simply lying low to avoid the struggles he'd faced since winning the lottery. According to public appeals, they indicated they'd leave Abraham be as long as he reached out to confirm he was okay. Police also considered that Abraham might have met with foul play. At the peak of his affluence, Abraham had drawn a lot of ire. Following his failed civil suit against Abraham, Michael Ford moved to Georgia where he resumed work as a truck driver. He said that he'd returned to Florida a couple of times, but maintained it was only for work. Michael said he hadn't seen Abraham since their court battle and he had no idea where he might have gone. An examination of Abraham's bank account revealed he'd made several withdrawals in the months leading up to his disappearance, but none since.
他们接受了这样一种可能性，即他只是为了避免自中彩票以来所面临的挣扎而躲了起来。根据公开呼吁，他们表示只要亚伯拉罕联系确认他没事，他们就会让他独处。警方也考虑过亚伯拉罕可能遭遇了不测。在他最富有的时候，亚伯拉罕招致了很多怨恨。在对亚伯拉罕的民事诉讼失败后，迈克尔·福特搬到了佐治亚州，在那里他恢复了卡车司机的工作。他说他回过佛罗里达几次，但坚称只是为了工作。迈克尔说，自他们的法庭之战以来，他再也没有见过亚伯拉罕，也不知道他可能去了哪里。对亚伯拉罕银行账户的审查显示，他在失踪前的几个月里进行了几次提款，但之后再也没有。
The account also revealed a harsh reality. Within three years, Abraham had spent, given away, or loaned almost all of his $17 million. Only $45,000 remained. While murder still couldn't be ruled out, it seemed highly unlikely that anyone would kill Abraham for such a small amount. He also had no life insurance, meaning no one stood to legally claim his remaining money upon his death. Detective David Wallace was part of a team fronting the search for Abraham Shakespeare. One day, he received a phone call from an anonymous male who asked for him specifically. When Detective Wallace asked who he was speaking to, the caller replied,
账户也揭示了一个残酷的现实。在三年内，亚伯拉罕已经花费、赠予或借出了他1700万美元中的几乎全部。只剩下4.5万美元。虽然不能排除谋杀的可能性，但似乎不太可能有人会为了这么少的钱而杀害亚伯拉罕。他也没有人寿保险，这意味着在他死后没有人能合法地索取他剩余的钱。大卫·华莱士侦探是负责搜寻亚伯拉罕·莎士比亚的团队成员之一。一天，他接到一个匿名男子的电话，对方专门找他。当华莱士侦探问他在和谁说话时，打电话的人回答说：
It don't matter who this is. I'm down here in Miami and just want to let you know I saw Abraham Shakespeare in a damn strip club. He reached in his pocket for something and his ID fell out and I saw it was him. Detective Wallace asked when, but the caller abruptly hung up. The call puzzled Detective Wallace. It wasn't traceable so he couldn't verify it. He was also aware that in high profile cases like Abraham's pranksters often stirred up mischief for police. Maybe someone was looking to insert themselves into the investigation or seeking the $5,000 reward for information. By Christmas, almost nine months had passed since the last confirmed sighting of Abraham.
“这不重要。我在迈阿密，只是想让你知道我在一家该死的脱衣舞俱乐部看到了亚伯拉罕·莎士比亚。他伸手去口袋拿东西时，身份证掉了出来，我看到是他。”华莱士侦探问是什么时候，但打电话的人突然挂断了。这个电话让华莱士侦探感到困惑。它无法追踪，所以他无法核实。他也意识到，在像亚伯拉罕这样备受瞩目的案件中，恶作剧者经常会为警方制造麻烦。也许有人想介入调查，或者想寻求5000美元的信息奖励。到圣诞节时，距离最后一次确认看到亚伯拉罕已经过去了近九个月。
Two days later, his mother Elizabeth received a call of her own. She remained calm when she heard the familiar voice of her missing son come through the line. Hey Ma, I just want you to know that I'm okay and I'm gonna see you soon. Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support case file to continue to deliver quality content. Abraham told his mother not to worry and said that he loved her. Elizabeth asked, where you at baby? Abraham remarked that it was too noisy for him to hear her clearly.
两天后，他的母亲伊丽莎白也接到了一个电话。当她听到失踪儿子熟悉的声音从电话那头传来时，她保持冷静。“嘿，妈，我只是想让你知道我很好，我很快就会见到你。”Casefile稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持Casefile继续提供高质量的内容。亚伯拉罕告诉母亲不要担心，并说他爱她。伊丽莎白问：“宝贝，你在哪儿？”亚伯拉罕说那里太吵了，他听不清她的话。
Elizabeth raised her voice again asking Abraham where he was and when he would be coming home. The phone line then went dead. Detectives traced the call to Barbara Greg Smith, Abraham's longtime friend and former employer. Greg was put under covert surveillance and detectives watched as he drove to a parking lot near Lakeland Mall. A second vehicle arrived shortly after driven by a middle-aged white woman with bleached blonde hair. She got out of her car and handed Greg some cash. He then drove off unaware he was being tailed by an unmarked police car. When Greg stopped at a red light, detectives surrounded his vehicle and ordered him out.
伊丽莎白再次提高嗓门，问亚伯拉罕他在哪里，什么时候回家。电话线随后断了。侦探们追踪到这个电话来自芭芭拉·格雷格·史密斯，亚伯拉罕的长期朋友和前雇主。格雷格被秘密监视，侦探们看着他开车前往莱克兰购物中心附近的一个停车场。不久后，第二辆车到达，由一名染着金发的中年白人女性驾驶。她下了车，给了格雷格一些现金。他随后开车离开，不知道自己被一辆未标记的警车跟踪。当格雷格在红灯处停下时，侦探们包围了他的车并命令他出来。
Greg appeared calm saying, I'm more than happy to talk to you all. Greg admitted to calling Abraham's mother and pretending to be her missing son. He also confessed to calling Detective David Wallace to report a false sighting of Abraham in Miami. Greg was apologetic. He said he'd been paid to make the calls by the woman he'd met in the Lakeland Mall parking lot. Her name was Dee Dee Moore. Greg thought he was doing Abraham a favour by making the calls, adding, I don't know anything about where Abraham is, why he's gone or when he's coming back.
格雷格显得很冷静，说：“我非常乐意和你们谈谈。”格雷格承认给亚伯拉罕的母亲打了电话，并假装是她失踪的儿子。他还承认给大卫·华莱士侦探打了电话，报告了在迈阿密看到亚伯拉罕的虚假消息。格雷格表示歉意。他说他是受他在莱克兰购物中心停车场遇到的那个女人的指使才打这些电话的。她的名字叫迪迪·摩尔。格雷格以为他在通过打这些电话帮亚伯拉罕一个忙，并补充说：“我不知道亚伯拉罕在哪里，他为什么离开，或者他什么时候回来。”
I've been trying to reach him myself. Detectives also spoke with Abraham's cousin, Cedric Adam, who said he'd received a birthday card and daily calls from Abraham. Cedric admitted he'd been lying. He claimed he'd been paid around $5,000 to spread the word that Abraham had gone away of his own accord. Cedric desperately needed money and only agreed because he thought it was harmless, just a way to help Abraham and to bait his aunt's worry. When asked who paid him to lie about Abraham, Cedric said,
“我自己也一直在试图联系他。”侦探们还与亚伯拉罕的表弟塞德里克·亚当谈过，他说他收到了亚伯拉罕的生日贺卡和每日电话。塞德里克承认他在撒谎。他声称他被支付了大约5000美元来散布亚伯拉罕是自愿离开的消息。塞德里克急需钱，他之所以同意只是因为他认为这无伤大雅，只是为了帮助亚伯拉罕并减轻他姑妈的担忧。当被问及是谁付钱让他撒谎时，塞德里克说：
this woman named Dee Dee Moore. Dee Dee Moore was a certified nurse's assistant who ran a nursing staffing agency called American Medical Professionals. In 2008, she attended a small business conference in Florida where she observed a panel discussion featuring a real estate agent. The agent spoke of having once sold a house to a lottery winner named Abraham Shakespeare. He had changed the way she viewed wealth, specifically that money does not equal happiness. After hearing Abraham's story, Dee Dee Moore was inspired to write about him for a magazine article. In October 2008, she arranged to meet Abraham.
“这个叫迪迪·摩尔的女人。”迪迪·摩尔是一名认证护理助理，经营着一家名为“美国医疗专业人员”的护理人员中介机构。2008年，她参加了佛罗里达州的一次小型商业会议，在那里她观察了一个由房地产经纪人参加的小组讨论。该经纪人谈到曾将一栋房子卖给了一位名叫亚伯拉罕·莎士比亚的彩票中奖者。他改变了她对财富的看法，特别是金钱并不等同于幸福。在听了亚伯拉罕的故事后，迪迪·摩尔受到启发，想为他写一篇杂志文章。2008年10月，她安排与亚伯拉罕见面。
By this point, his $17 million had been whittled down significantly. He had a little over a million dollars left, along with just $3 million worth of assets. Dee Dee quickly realized that his rags to riches story was in fact a riches to rags one. She witnessed firsthand the antlers pestering Abraham endured from those seeking what little money he had left. He was downtrodden and distrustful. When Dee Dee pitched her article idea in which she intended to highlight Abraham's generosity and kindness, he became noticeably upbeat. Dee Dee filmed a candid interview with Abraham as he watched a live feed from the various security cameras positioned around his home.
到那时，他的1700万美元已经被大幅削减。他只剩下不到一百万美元，以及价值仅300万美元的资产。迪迪很快意识到，他从贫穷到富有的故事实际上是一个从富有到贫穷的故事。她亲眼目睹了亚伯拉罕从那些想要他剩下的一点钱的人那里受到的无休止的骚扰。他垂头丧气且充满怀疑。当迪迪提出她的文章构思，即打算突出亚伯拉罕的慷慨和善良时，他明显变得开朗起来。迪迪拍摄了一段与亚伯拉罕的坦诚采访，当时他正在观看安装在他家周围的各种安全摄像头的实时画面。
Dee Dee asked if he ever got tired of people asking him for money. Abraham replied, I've been tired. They don't take no for an answer, so I just let him keep on keeping on asking. In time, Abraham confided in Dee Dee about his dire financial straits. He'd followed poor advice and failed to invest his money wisely. Dee Dee felt sorry for him. She offered to protect Abraham from being taken advantage of any further. Although she was shy and meek, she pursued those who had borrowed money from Abraham and ensured they made repayments. She also organized for Judy Hagens to have power of attorney over Abraham's remaining money.
迪迪问他是否厌倦了人们向他要钱。亚伯拉罕回答说：“我早就厌倦了。他们不接受拒绝，所以我只能让他们继续问下去。”随着时间的推移，亚伯拉罕向迪迪吐露了他严峻的财务状况。他听信了糟糕的建议，没能明智地投资他的钱。迪迪为他感到难过。她主动提出保护亚伯拉罕，不再让他被利用。尽管她害羞且温顺，但她还是追讨了那些向亚伯拉罕借钱的人，并确保他们还款。她还安排朱迪·哈根斯获得亚伯拉罕剩余资金的授权委托。
This meant anyone who wanted funds would have to go through duty. Abraham had been moving his money from bank to bank on a whim. Dee Dee advised him to secure his leftover money in a single Bank of America account under his own name. Dee Dee, Abraham and Judy got together periodically to discuss Abraham's finances with Dee Dee keeping record of the meetings for the bank. She was dismayed to learn that Abraham was using his money for what she had noted as criminal activity. He was removed as an authorized signer of his account, leaving just Dee Dee and Judy with access. They became a buffer between Abraham and any unwise financial decisions. Dee Dee also helped to manage all of Abraham's assets, including his property.
这意味着任何想要资金的人都必须通过朱迪。亚伯拉罕一直随心所欲地在银行之间转移他的钱。迪迪建议他将剩余的钱存入他自己名下的一个美国银行账户中。迪迪、亚伯拉罕和朱迪定期聚在一起讨论亚伯拉罕的财务状况，迪迪为银行记录了会议内容。她沮丧地发现亚伯拉罕正在将他的钱用于她所记录的犯罪活动。他被取消了账户授权签字人的资格，只剩下迪迪和朱迪有权访问。他们成为了亚伯拉罕和任何不明智财务决策之间的缓冲。迪迪还帮助管理亚伯拉罕的所有资产，包括他的房产。
Dee Dee encouraged Abraham to start living his life. In their recorded interview, she asked where he would like to go. He responded, It don't matter to me, I'm not a picky person. Dee Dee offered suggestions, California, a foreign country. Seemingly irritated by Dee Dee's prying, Abraham motioned for her to turn off the camera. Are you gonna miss your home, Dee Dee asked. Abraham responded,
迪迪鼓励亚伯拉罕开始过自己的生活。在他们录制的采访中，她问他想去哪里。他回答说：“对我来说无所谓，我不是一个挑剔的人。”迪迪提出了建议，加利福尼亚，一个外国。亚伯拉罕似乎对迪迪的打探感到恼火，示意她关掉摄像机。“你会想念你的家吗？”迪迪问。亚伯拉罕回答说：
Yep, but life goes on. Dee Dee got the sense that Abraham was planning to take off at any moment. Then one day he told her he'd obtained a fake passport under the name Rod Regas. Abraham began working to break his ties to Lakeland as quickly as possible. He offered to sell Dee Dee his house for a little over $500,000. She didn't have that much money, but the pair reached an agreement. Dee Dee could live in the house and make small purchases for Abraham such as flights or cruise tickets as a gradual means of paying off the debt. Abraham then asked for Dee Dee's help to make him disappear.
“是的，但生活还要继续。”迪迪感觉到亚伯拉罕正计划随时离开。然后有一天，他告诉她他以“罗德·雷加斯”的名字获得了一本假护照。亚伯拉罕开始努力尽快切断与莱克兰的联系。他提出以50多万美元的价格把房子卖给迪迪。她没有那么多钱，但两人达成了一项协议。迪迪可以住在房子里，并为亚伯拉罕进行小额购买，例如机票或游轮票，作为逐步偿还债务的一种方式。亚伯拉罕随后请求迪迪帮助他消失。
Having grown attached to Abraham and his plight, she agreed. When Abraham left Lakeland, Dee Dee spread conflicting rumors about where he'd gone and why to prevent him from being traced. She also shared alleged sightings of Abraham so people knew he was alright. He had left Dee Dee his cell phone, allowing her to send texts on his behalf to his friends and family. Whenever concerns for Abraham grew, Dee Dee used money he had given her to pay people to claim they'd heard from him. She paid Greg Smith $300 to call Detective David Wallace and report a false sighting of Abraham in Miami. She gave Greg a further $350 to call Abraham's mother. She'd even broken attorney-client privilege by staging a call to Abraham's attorney in October.
由于对亚伯拉罕和他的困境产生了感情，她同意了。当亚伯拉罕离开莱克兰时，迪迪散布了关于他去了哪里以及原因的相互矛盾的谣言，以防止他被追踪。她还分享了所谓的亚伯拉罕的目击消息，让人们知道他很好。他把手机留给了迪迪，让她可以代表他给朋友和家人发短信。每当人们对亚伯拉罕的担忧增加时，迪迪就用他给她的钱付钱给别人，让他们声称收到过他的消息。她付给格雷格·史密斯300美元，让他给大卫·华莱士侦探打电话，报告在迈阿密看到亚伯拉罕的虚假消息。她又给了格雷格350美元，让他给亚伯拉罕的母亲打电话。她甚至在10月份通过安排给亚伯拉罕的律师打电话，打破了律师与客户的特权。
Abraham had told her, you handle all the business, I got to go. When approached by detectives, Dee Dee became emotional as she divulged what she'd done. She claimed not to know where Abraham was, but maintained that the two had met up and spoken since he fell off the grid in April 2009. Dee Dee said she'd initially been under the impression that she was simply keeping things in order until Abraham came home. But over time, she suspected he never intended to return. She felt she had misjudged him, saying, I've got all this trouble on me when all I was trying to do is help the man. Dee Dee willingly assisted investigators with their inquiries. Eventually, she admitted there were several other reasons Abraham might have fled.
亚伯拉罕曾告诉她：“你处理所有的生意，我得走了。”当侦探们接近时，迪迪在透露她所做的事情时变得情绪激动。她声称不知道亚伯拉罕在哪里，但坚称自2009年4月他失踪以来，两人见过面并交谈过。迪迪说她最初以为自己只是在亚伯拉罕回家之前把事情处理好。但随着时间的推移，她怀疑他从未打算回来。她觉得她误判了他，说：“我惹上了这么多麻烦，而我所做的只是想帮助那个人。”迪迪自愿协助调查人员进行调查。最终，她承认亚伯拉罕可能逃跑还有其他几个原因。
She disclosed that the real reason Abraham had her manage his money was to avoid paying child support. He also had a drug problem and might have been lured into dealing in a desperate bid to rebuild his wealth. Then Dee Dee mentioned an incriminating videotape. It allegedly showed footage of Abraham, quote, having sex with a 14-year-old girl. Whatever the case, Abraham's friends and associates in Lakeland agreed on one thing. If anyone knew where Abraham was, it was Dee Dee Moore. Dee Dee's admissions put her directly in the spotlight. Reporters confronted her in public, police constantly requested interviews and her computer files and business records were taken for examination.
她透露，亚伯拉罕让她管理钱财的真正原因是想逃避支付子女抚养费。他还有毒瘾，可能在重建财富的绝望尝试中被诱骗去贩毒。随后，迪迪提到了录像带的罪证。据称，录像中显示亚伯拉罕“与一名14岁女孩发生性关系”。无论事实如何，亚伯拉罕在莱克兰的朋友和熟人们都达成了一点共识：如果有人知道亚伯拉罕在哪里，那一定是迪迪·摩尔。迪迪的供述让她直接成为了焦点。记者在公共场合质问她，警察不断要求采访，她的电脑文件和商业记录也被带走调查。
To quell the mounting suspicion against her, Dee Dee did her own work to find Abraham. She met up with Greg Smith, the man she'd previously paid to make fraudulent calls on Abraham's behalf. Dee Dee ventured to Greg about the stress she was under and to Greg reassured her that he would help until Abraham reappeared. Dee Dee's demeanour suddenly changed. She clawed at Greg's chest, looking for a listening device. Greg pulled away angrily, asking, what the fuck you're doing? Dee Dee composed herself and apologised. She was riddled with anxiety and paranoia and didn't know who to trust.
为了平息针对她日益增长的怀疑，迪迪自己动手寻找亚伯拉罕。她见了格雷格·史密斯，那个她之前花钱雇来冒充亚伯拉罕打电话的人。迪迪向格雷格倾诉了她所承受的压力，格雷格安慰她说，在亚伯拉罕出现之前，他会一直帮忙。迪迪的神情突然变了。她抓挠着格雷格的胸口，寻找窃听器。格雷格愤怒地推开她，问她到底在干什么。迪迪稳住情绪并道歉。她充满了焦虑和偏执，不知道该信任谁。
She blamed Abraham for leaving her to clean up his mess and Greg consoled her. Dee Dee cried and told him, I see why Abraham says you're a good friend. I just want to thank you for believing in me and being on my side. December 2009 came to a close with no sign of Abraham Shakespeare. In late January 2010, Dee Dee Moore met with Greg Smith again. The pair spoke about how the police were purposefully stirring shit up by intimidating Abraham's support network. Phones had been tapped, homes were searched and property seized. Dee Dee believed the police were trying to get them to change their story.
她责怪亚伯拉罕把烂摊子留给她收拾，格雷格安慰了她。迪迪哭着对他说：“我明白亚伯拉罕为什么说你是个好朋友了。我只想感谢你相信我，站在我这边。”2009年12月在没有亚伯拉罕·莎士比亚的消息中结束了。2010年1月底，迪迪·摩尔再次与格雷格·史密斯会面。两人谈到警察是如何通过恐吓亚伯拉罕的支持网络来故意挑起事端的。电话被窃听，房屋被搜查，财产被没收。迪迪认为警察是想让他们改变说辞。
Greg encouraged her to remain strong, reminding her that they were in this together. I've only been talking to you because I'm trying to find Abraham, Dee Dee said. I've never been so scared in my life. Tensions were growing in the Lakeland community. People were accusing Dee Dee of ripping off Abraham and she feared violent reprisal. She informed Greg that Abraham was connected to several gun and drug dealers and this made her particularly nervous. Dee Dee had told the police who these men were, prompting the police to confront them with Dee Dee's accusations. That was when she realized that the police didn't care if she was killed.
格雷格鼓励她保持坚强，提醒她他们是一条船上的。迪迪说：“我一直和你说话是因为我在努力寻找亚伯拉罕。我这辈子从来没这么害怕过。”莱克兰社区的紧张局势正在加剧。人们指责迪迪欺骗了亚伯拉罕，她担心遭到暴力报复。她告诉格雷格，亚伯拉罕与几名枪支和毒品贩子有联系，这让她特别紧张。迪迪已经告诉警察这些人是谁，导致警察拿着迪迪的指控去与他们对质。就在那时，她意识到警察根本不在乎她是否会被杀。
Dee Dee also told Greg that she'd been approached by Abraham's cousin, Cedric Adam, whom she'd previously paid to lie about Abraham. Cedric told Dee Dee that he'd been in contact with Abraham and said he wanted Cedric to have his home on Red Hawk Bend Drive. Dee Dee was unsure what to do about this. If it was true, Cedric could establish a line of communication between Abraham and the authorities. Yet Cedric wasn't exactly credible. Then there was Dee Dee's own distrust of the police. She had grown to suspect that they were trying to frame her for Abraham's disappearance. Dee Dee and Greg bought burner cell phones so they could communicate freely.
迪迪还告诉格雷格，亚伯拉罕的表弟塞德里克·亚当曾找过她，她之前曾花钱让他就亚伯拉罕的事撒谎。塞德里克告诉迪迪，他一直与亚伯拉罕有联系，并说亚伯拉罕想让塞德里克拥有他在红鹰弯道的房子。迪迪不知道该怎么处理这件事。如果这是真的，塞德里克可能会在亚伯拉罕和当局之间建立联系。然而，塞德里克并不完全可信。此外，迪迪自己也不信任警察。她开始怀疑他们试图陷害她，让她为亚伯拉罕的失踪负责。迪迪和格雷格买了预付费手机，以便自由沟通。
One night they met at a comfort inn where Greg booked a room under a fake name. Dee Dee was first to arrive. Anxious about leaving any trace of her presence, she donned plastic gloves, a surgical mask, disposable shoe covers and a hair net. When Greg showed up, he put on the same protective outfit. Dee Dee was fed up and had decided to take matters into her own hands. She pulled out a laptop and printer. With Greg's help, she started typing a letter addressed to Abraham Shakespeare's mother, Elizabeth. But the letter wasn't going to be from Dee Dee.
一天晚上，他们在一家舒适旅馆见面，格雷格用假名订了房间。迪迪先到。由于担心留下任何痕迹，她戴上了塑料手套、外科口罩、一次性鞋套和发网。格雷格出现时，也穿上了同样的防护装备。迪迪受够了，决定亲自处理这件事。她拿出笔记本电脑和打印机。在格雷格的帮助下，她开始写一封寄给亚伯拉罕·莎士比亚母亲伊丽莎白的信。但这封信不是以迪迪的名义写的。
She was writing it as though it was from Abraham himself. Convinced that Abraham wasn't coming back to help her, Dee Dee was desperate to redirect the investigative spotlight. Greg advised her, Don't mention yourself too much, otherwise it will come off as suspicious. The letter was several pages long and gave various reasons why Abraham wanted to leave home. Dee Dee wrote, I like being missing, just not all over the news. I've been through a lot mum, you know it, I'm just tired.
她写得好像是亚伯拉罕本人写的。迪迪确信亚伯拉罕不会回来帮她，于是拼命想转移调查的焦点。格雷格建议她：“别过多提到你自己，否则会显得很可疑。”这封信有几页长，给出了亚伯拉罕想离家的各种理由。迪迪写道：“我喜欢失踪的感觉，只是不想上新闻。妈，我经历了很多，你知道的，我只是累了。”
She made up a story that someone had recognized Abraham and he'd had to pay a police officer $20,000 to keep his secret. In reference to herself, Dee Dee wrote, Don't worry about Dee, if she goes to jail she will be okay, the charges won't stick. There are too many people that know why I left, I gave her enough money, she knew what to expect. She should have not gotten involved, so now she just has to deal with it. Remembering that Abraham was illiterate and incapable of writing long-winded prose, Dee Dee added, I still can't write a letter, a good friend is typing it for me. I will see you, I promise, just give me some time.
她编造了一个故事，说有人认出了亚伯拉罕，他不得不付给一名警察2万美元来保守秘密。在提到自己时，迪迪写道：“别担心迪，如果她坐牢，她会没事的，指控不会成立。有太多人知道我为什么离开，我给了她足够的钱，她知道会发生什么。她本不该卷入其中，所以现在她只能自己处理了。”想到亚伯拉罕目不识丁，写不出长篇大论，迪迪补充道：“我还是不会写信，是一个好朋友在帮我打字。我会见你的，我保证，只是给我一点时间。”
Greg Smith was impressed, the letter didn't sound like it had come from Dee Dee at all. They printed it off and slid it into an envelope. The pair wiped the room down with towels, then they drove to Abraham's mother's home where Greg placed the letter in her mailbox. But any hopes that the letter would help Dee Dee were dashed when it failed to make the news? Elizabeth didn't speak about it publicly and the police seemed unaware of its existence. Instead, investigators upped the reward for information to $10,000 with the promise that any tipsters wouldn't have to testify in future court proceedings. The county sheriff announced, None of the circumstances and none of the investigation we've completed up to this point leads us to believe Abraham Shakespeare is still alive.
格雷格·史密斯印象深刻，这封信听起来一点也不像出自迪迪之手。他们打印出来并塞进信封。两人用毛巾擦拭了房间，然后开车去亚伯拉罕母亲家，格雷格把信放进了她的邮箱。但任何希望这封信能帮助迪迪的想法都在它未能登上新闻后破灭了。伊丽莎白没有公开谈论它，警察似乎也不知道它的存在。相反，调查人员将悬赏金提高到1万美元，并承诺举报人将来不必在法庭诉讼中作证。县治安官宣布：“到目前为止，我们完成的所有调查情况都没有让我们相信亚伯拉罕·莎士比亚还活着。”
They officially named Dee Dee more as a person of interest. Dee Dee was destroyed. Had Elizabeth kept the letter to herself? Or were the police just keeping it on the down low? Dee Dee called Greg Smith for guidance, expressing her devastation that police feared Abraham was dead and that she was being viewed as a suspect. Fuck all that, Greg told her. They don't have a body. Dee Dee brushed his reassurances aside, saying, Yeah, but that doesn't seem to matter to these assholes. They're just trying to pin something on me and I haven't done anything to the man. I would never ever do anything to hurt another human being. All I have ever done is try to help Abraham. Hours later, Greg agreed to meet Dee Dee at a service station in Plant City, 10 miles west of Lakeland.
他们正式将迪迪·摩尔列为相关人员。迪迪崩溃了。是伊丽莎白把信藏起来了吗？还是警察在低调处理？迪迪打电话给格雷格·史密斯寻求指导，表达了她对警察担心亚伯拉罕已死以及她被视为嫌疑人的绝望。格雷格告诉她：“去他的。他们没有尸体。”迪迪不理会他的安慰，说：“是啊，但这对这些混蛋来说似乎不重要。他们只是想把罪名扣在我头上，我并没有对那个人做任何事。我永远不会伤害另一个人。我所做的一切只是想帮助亚伯拉罕。”几小时后，格雷格同意在莱克兰以西10英里的植物城的一个加油站与迪迪见面。
As soon as Greg pulled up, a visibly overjoyed Dee Dee rushed over to his car, yelling, Abraham's back. Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Case File to continue to deliver quality content. Dee Dee could barely contain her excitement. Someone had called her to report seeing Abraham at a home near Walden Lake. Dee Dee had gone to the location herself and spotted a car with a figure inside. She was certain it was Abraham. Greg was floored. He and Dee Dee went to the location but the car was no longer there. Regardless, Dee Dee was relieved. Soon, other alleged sightings of Abraham began to spread, but to Dee Dee's disappointment, none of them made the news.
格雷格刚停下车，明显欣喜若狂的迪迪就冲向他的车，大喊：“亚伯拉罕回来了。”案件档案稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集赞助商来支持我们。感谢您收听本集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持案件档案继续提供高质量的内容。迪迪几乎无法抑制她的兴奋。有人打电话给她，报告说在瓦尔登湖附近的一所房子里看到了亚伯拉罕。迪迪亲自去了那个地点，发现了一辆车，里面有一个人影。她确信那是亚伯拉罕。格雷格惊呆了。他和迪迪去了那个地点，但车已经不在了。无论如何，迪迪感到如释重负。很快，其他关于亚伯拉罕的所谓目击事件开始流传，但令迪迪失望的是，没有一个上了新闻。
Greg tried to reassure her that the media were probably just being cautious given the case was riddled with rumours. Deflated, Dee Dee told Greg, The police don't care. They just want to make me the full guy for Abraham not being around. Greg replied, Well, you need your own full guy. You need somebody who will take this case for you. Take the rap. He suggested Dee Dee find someone who was about to serve a long prison sentence and cut a deal with them. What deal you cut is between you and him, Greg continued. I'm just saying there are people who will do this for you and get the heat off us. Dee Dee was excited by Greg's proposition. She asked if he had anyone in mind.
格雷格试图安慰她，说媒体可能只是因为案件充斥着谣言而保持谨慎。迪迪泄气地告诉格雷格：“警察不在乎。他们只是想让我成为亚伯拉罕不在场的替罪羊。”格雷格回答说：“好吧，你需要你自己的替罪羊。你需要一个能为你承担这个案子的人。顶罪。”他建议迪迪找一个即将服长期刑期的人，并与他们达成交易。格雷格继续说：“你达成什么交易是你和他之间的事。我只是说有些人会为你做这件事，让我们摆脱困境。”迪迪对格雷格的提议感到兴奋。她问他是否有合适的人选。
Greg said he had a cousin named Mike Smith who was about to serve 25 years on drug charges. Dee Dee tearfully embraced Greg, grateful that he was still supporting her. He was, in her eyes, an exceptional person. Greg reiterated that he had been with Dee Dee since the beginning and would remain with her for the whole way. The pair approached Mike Smith with their proposal. In exchange for $50,000, Mike would tell police that Abraham owed him money for a cannabis deal. Because Dee Dee had been overseeing Abraham's money, she would say that Abraham requested the funds from her but she refused. The confrontation eventually ensued between the two men and Abraham pulled out a gun, prompting Mike to shoot him in self-defense. Mike Smith agreed to become Dee Dee and Greg's fall guy. The money would provide security for his family and given he was going to prison anyway, he felt he had nothing to lose. While Dee Dee was relieved by what she saw as a foolproof plan, she was starting to worry that maybe Abraham wasn't alright.
格雷格说他有一个表弟叫迈克·史密斯，因毒品指控即将服刑25年。迪迪含泪拥抱了格雷格，感谢他一直支持她。在她眼里，他是一个杰出的人。格雷格重申，他从一开始就和迪迪在一起，并将全程陪伴她。两人带着他们的提议找到了迈克·史密斯。作为5万美元的回报，迈克会告诉警察亚伯拉罕欠他大麻交易的钱。因为迪迪一直负责亚伯拉罕的钱，她会说亚伯拉罕向她要钱，但她拒绝了。两人最终发生了冲突，亚伯拉罕掏出一把枪，促使迈克出于自卫开枪射杀了他。迈克·史密斯同意成为迪迪和格雷格的替罪羊。这笔钱将为他的家人提供保障，而且既然他无论如何都要坐牢，他觉得没什么可失去的。虽然迪迪对她认为万无一失的计划感到宽慰，但她开始担心亚伯拉罕可能真的出事了。
Perhaps he had been killed after all and those who knew the truth were being threatened to stay quiet. Dee Dee's suspicions fell on a man she knew only as Ronald, the worst of the gun and drug dealers Abraham associated with. In the wake of Abraham's disappearance, Ronald had initially told Dee Dee that Abraham was okay. But as she'd started to sense that something was amiss, Ronald became aggressive, threatening to kill Dee Dee and her teenage son. Menacing notes began appearing at Dee Dee's back door, which she was certain were from Ronald. Greg encouraged Dee Dee to confront Ronald, even suggesting she bribed him to reveal key information. Dee Dee considered it, but was more tempted by Mike Smith being willing to take the rap for Abraham's murder. This would take the heat off Dee Dee entirely. The only problem was that Mike had made a specific request. He needed a body.
也许他毕竟被杀了，而那些知道真相的人正受到威胁而保持沉默。迪迪的怀疑落在一个她只知道叫罗纳德的人身上，他是亚伯拉罕交往过的最糟糕的枪支和毒品贩子之一。在亚伯拉罕失踪后，罗纳德最初告诉迪迪亚伯拉罕没事。但当她开始感觉到有些不对劲时，罗纳德变得咄咄逼人，威胁要杀死迪迪和她十几岁的儿子。迪迪的后门开始出现威胁性的字条，她确信是罗纳德写的。格雷格鼓励迪迪与罗纳德对质，甚至建议她贿赂他以获取关键信息。迪迪考虑过，但更被迈克·史密斯愿意为亚伯拉罕的谋杀顶罪所吸引。这将使迪迪完全摆脱嫌疑。唯一的问题是迈克提出了一个具体要求。他需要一具尸体。
No one would take his story seriously without one and it would remove any doubt that Abraham was still alive. Because they didn't have a body, Dee Dee hoped a murder weapon would suffice. They could plant Mike's fingerprints on a gun and then have Mike direct people to the weapon. She even had one they could use, a .38 caliber Smith & Wesson revolver. Although it was registered in Dee Dee's name, Mike could say that he'd stolen it from her house, or she could say that she'd sold it to Abraham. Better still, they could remove the weapon's serial number to prevent it being traced all together. Mike was reluctant to go through with the plan without a body. He knew of someone who had attempted a similar con, but the supposed murder victim had suddenly reappeared.
没有尸体，没人会认真对待他的故事，而且这会消除亚伯拉罕还活着的任何疑虑。因为他们没有尸体，迪迪希望凶器就足够了。他们可以把迈克的指纹留在枪上，然后让迈克引导人们找到凶器。她甚至有一把他们可以用的枪，一把.38口径的史密斯威森左轮手枪。虽然它是以迪迪的名义注册的，但迈克可以说他是从她家偷的，或者她可以说她把它卖给了亚伯拉罕。更好的是，他们可以磨掉武器的序列号，以防止它被追踪。迈克不愿在没有尸体的情况下执行计划。他知道有人尝试过类似的骗局，但所谓的谋杀受害者突然又出现了。
All the conspirators were charged with insurance fraud. This rattled Dee Dee and she began to doubt the plan. Confronting Ronald seemed safer. Perhaps she could offer him something to elicit a confession and the location of Abraham's body. Greg ordered Dee Dee to call Ronald and find out everything they needed to know. The next time Greg and Dee Dee met, she had an update. She'd gotten in contact with Ronald and he'd told her everything. Abraham had indeed run afoul of the drug dealers and was killed as a result. Ronald had intended to set Dee Dee up for the crime and admitted that he'd buried Abraham's body on her property in Plant City.
所有共谋者都被指控保险欺诈。这让迪迪感到不安，她开始怀疑这个计划。与罗纳德对质似乎更安全。也许她可以给他一些东西来诱导他招供并说出亚伯拉罕尸体的位置。格雷格命令迪迪打电话给罗纳德，找出他们需要知道的一切。格雷格和迪迪下次见面时，她有了最新消息。她已经联系上了罗纳德，他告诉了她一切。亚伯拉罕确实得罪了毒贩，结果被杀了。罗纳德打算陷害迪迪，并承认他把亚伯拉罕的尸体埋在了她在植物城的房产里。
Dee Dee and Greg made a plan. Under the cover of darkness, Greg and Mike would dig up Abraham's body. Dee Dee would stay at Abraham's Lakeland home with her family, establishing her alibi. She suggested that Abraham's body be taken out to the countryside and burnt. She gave Greg her revolver to prepare it for Mike's confession before making a final revelation. Abraham was rumoured to have been in possession of $67,000 when he was killed. She told Greg and Mike to search for it. In the early afternoon of Monday, January 25, 2010, Greg arrived at Dee Dee's house on the regional outskirts of Plant City.
迪迪和格雷格制定了一个计划。在夜色的掩护下，格雷格和迈克将挖出亚伯拉罕的尸体。迪迪将和家人留在亚伯拉罕的莱克兰家中，建立她的不在场证明。她建议把亚伯拉罕的尸体带到乡下烧掉。她把左轮手枪给了格雷格，以便在做出最终揭露之前为迈克的供词做准备。据传亚伯拉罕被杀时身上有6.7万美元。她告诉格雷格和迈克去寻找它。2010年1月25日星期一的下午早些时候，格雷格到达了迪迪位于植物城郊区的房子。
She supplied him with digging implements and cleaning products before leading him to a 30 by 30 foot concrete slab in her backyard. She pinpointed a specific spot, saying, That's where you should dig, right under there, maybe six feet down. Later that night, Dee Dee was in Lakeland as planned when she received a call from Greg. He thundered down the line. What the fuck are you doing? He'd arrived at Dee Dee's to commence the dig, only to find a large police presence already there. Greg and Mike backed away to a secluded spot and called Dee Dee, accusing her of setting them up.
她为他提供了挖掘工具和清洁用品，然后带他来到后院一块30乘30英尺的混凝土板前。她指出了一个特定的位置，说：“你应该在那里挖，就在下面，大概六英尺深。”那天晚上晚些时候，迪迪按计划在莱克兰，这时她接到了格雷格的电话。他在电话那头咆哮道：“你到底在干什么？”他到达迪迪家准备开始挖掘，却发现那里已经有大量警察。格雷格和迈克退到一个僻静的地方给迪迪打电话，指责她陷害他们。
I swear to you, Greg, she told him, I don't know nothing about this. Greg demanded to meet up. Dee Dee was reluctant as it would blow her alibi. But Greg was furious. They needed a plan B and they needed it now. Dee Dee agreed to meet Greg at the Lakeland Mall parking lot. She told her family that she was going to help a friend who was having car trouble. The pair sat in Greg's car, frantically discussing their options.
“格雷格，我向你发誓，”她告诉他，“我对这件事一无所知。”格雷格要求见面。迪迪很不情愿，因为这会破坏她的不在场证明。但格雷格很愤怒。他们需要B计划，而且现在就需要。迪迪同意在莱克兰购物中心的停车场与格雷格见面。她告诉家人她要去帮一个车坏了的朋友。两人坐在格雷格的车里，疯狂地讨论他们的选择。
Greg suspected the police were tipped off and had a warrant to search Dee Dee's property, but Dee Dee maintained that she hadn't told anyone about their scheme. All of a sudden, two cars sped into the parking lot and pulled up beside Greg's vehicle. Detectives emerged and took Greg and Dee Dee into custody. Dee Dee immediately threw Greg under the bus, saying that he had killed Abraham. The interviewing detectives eyed each other before one remarked, You know that Greg didn't kill Abraham Shakespeare. Dee Dee began to cry, but insisted that Greg was guilty.
格雷格怀疑警察得到了线报，并有搜查迪迪房产的搜查令，但迪迪坚持说她没有告诉任何人他们的计划。突然，两辆车加速冲进停车场，停在格雷格的车旁。侦探们出现并将格雷格和迪迪拘留。迪迪立即把格雷格推出来顶罪，说他杀了亚伯拉罕。审讯的侦探们面面相觑，其中一人评论道：“你知道格雷格没有杀亚伯拉罕·莎士比亚。”迪迪开始哭泣，但坚持认为格雷格有罪。
Then she was given news that left her speechless. Greg Smith is working with us. Greg Smith was first introduced to Dee Dee more by his good friend Abraham Shakespeare. Dee Dee, whose full name was the Reese Donegan Moore, came across as timid and uneasy. Her handshake was gentle and she struggled to maintain eye contact. When Dee Dee began managing Abraham's money, Greg was skeptical. She wasn't an accredited accountant or financial advisor. She claimed to have written a financial self-help book called Organize Me Now,
然后她得到了一个让她目瞪口呆的消息。格雷格·史密斯正在与我们合作。格雷格·史密斯最初是由他的好朋友亚伯拉罕·莎士比亚介绍给迪迪·摩尔的。迪迪，全名是里斯·多尼根·摩尔，看起来胆小且不安。她的握手很轻，很难保持眼神交流。当迪迪开始管理亚伯拉罕的钱时，格雷格持怀疑态度。她不是认证会计师或财务顾问。她声称写了一本名为《现在就整理我》的财务自助书，
but it hadn't been published. Greg bit his tongue so as not to undermine Abraham's decision, but warned him to be careful. He never saw his friend again. With Abraham mysteriously out of the picture, Dee Dee started chasing Greg to repay the $63,000 that Abraham had lent him for his mortgage. Then, when Abraham was reported missing, Dee Dee offered to eradicate the debt entirely, on one condition. She needed Greg's help to mislead the police. Dee Dee knew detectives would be on to her. From a young age, she was acutely aware of the power and privilege of wealth and was ashamed of her own family's financial status.
但它并没有出版。格雷格咬住舌头，以免破坏亚伯拉罕的决定，但警告他要小心。他再也没有见过他的朋友。随着亚伯拉罕神秘地消失，迪迪开始追着格雷格偿还亚伯拉罕借给他用于抵押贷款的6.3万美元。然后，当亚伯拉罕被报告失踪时，迪迪提出完全免除这笔债务，但有一个条件。她需要格雷格的帮助来误导警察。迪迪知道侦探们会盯上她。从小，她就敏锐地意识到财富的力量和特权，并为自己家庭的经济状况感到羞耻。
In her teens, she made her parents drop her off away from her friends so they wouldn't see their cheap old car. She sought luxuries her parents couldn't afford, like expensive clothing, cars and a jewellery. At age 22, Dee Dee was involved in a head-on collision. The two occupants in the other vehicle were killed, but Dee Dee made a full recovery. Afterwards, Dee Dee's mother noticed an erratic shift in her daughter's behavior that left her wondering if Dee Dee had an undetected brain injury. Her job as a nursing assistant suited her seemingly kind and patient personality, but it didn't pay well. Still fixated on money, Dee Dee established a moderately successful side business selling prepaid cell phones and calling plans. Colleagues recalled Dee Dee's natural acumen for business, but it was soon revealed that she had skimmed $60,000 off the payroll.
十几岁时，她让父母把她放在离朋友很远的地方，这样他们就不会看到他们廉价的旧车。她追求父母负担不起的奢侈品，如昂贵的衣服、汽车和珠宝。22岁时，迪迪卷入了一场正面碰撞。另一辆车里的两名乘客死亡，但迪迪完全康复了。事后，迪迪的母亲注意到女儿的行为出现了不稳定的转变，这让她怀疑迪迪是否有未被发现的脑损伤。她作为护理助理的工作适合她看似善良和耐心的性格，但薪水不高。仍然沉迷于金钱，迪迪建立了一项适度成功的副业，销售预付费手机和通话套餐。同事们回忆起迪迪天生的商业头脑，但很快发现她从工资单中挪用了6万美元。
Dee Dee's money woes continued. She was caught shoplifting and arrested for writing a bad cheque. She failed to make her car repayments and was evicted for failing to pay rent. By mid-2001, she owed upwards of $50,000. Not long after this, Dee Dee was discovered in Waimama, 40 miles south from her home in Plant City. She was dishevelled and distraught, with her wrists bound with duct tape. Dee Dee told police that three clean-cut, tattooed Hispanic men had carjacked her at gunpoint. They abducted and raped her, then thrown her in a ditch before taking off in her car. A tip-off led to the discovery of Dee Dee's car in a garage 30 miles north in Pasco County and the complete unraveling of her story.
迪迪的经济困境仍在继续。她因入店行窃被抓，并因开空头支票被捕。她没能偿还车贷，并因未付房租被驱逐。到2001年中期，她欠债超过5万美元。不久之后，迪迪在距离她植物城家40英里的怀马马被发现。她衣衫褴褛，心烦意乱，手腕被胶带绑着。迪迪告诉警察，三名干净利落、有纹身的西班牙裔男子持枪劫持了她。他们绑架并强奸了她，然后把她扔进沟里，随后开着她的车逃跑了。一条线索导致在北面30英里的帕斯科县的一个车库里发现了迪迪的车，她的故事彻底破灭了。
Dee Dee had paid an accomplice to help stage the attack so she could claim insurance on her stolen car. She was convicted of insurance fraud and falsely reporting a crime and given a year's probation. Years later in 2006, Dee Dee was accused of stealing $60,000 that was given to her to start a new business. The case was closed due to a lack of evidence. After this, Dee Dee faced two civil lawsuits for unpaid services. Fronting her new venture, American Medical Professionals, she attended the Small Business Conference that ultimately led her to Abraham Shakespeare. Within 90 days of the pair meeting, Dee Dee more virtually had complete control of Abraham's money. Investigators discovered that the final withdrawals from Abraham's bank account as well as his assets were transferred to the business account of American Medical Professionals.
迪迪付钱给一名同伙帮助策划了这次袭击，以便她能为被盗的汽车申请保险。她因保险欺诈和虚假报告犯罪被定罪，并被判处一年缓刑。多年后的2006年，迪迪被指控窃取了给她的6万美元用于开展新业务。该案因证据不足而结案。此后，迪迪面临两起未付服务费的民事诉讼。在她的新企业“美国医疗专业人员”的带领下，她参加了最终让她结识亚伯拉罕·莎士比亚的小企业会议。两人见面90天内，迪迪·摩尔几乎完全控制了亚伯拉罕的钱。调查人员发现，亚伯拉罕银行账户的最后提款以及他的资产都被转移到了“美国医疗专业人员”的商业账户中。
Around this time, Dee Dee made large withdrawals from this account purchasing jewelry and several high-end cars as well as paying for restaurant meals and travel. While Dee Dee was seemingly helping Abraham reclaim money he'd loaned to others, the repayments actually went straight to her. Dee Dee claimed to have bought Abraham's mansion home from him but there was no documentation to prove it. When detectives confronted her with this discrepancy and many others, Dee Dee altered her story with even more outlandish explanations. Some were willing to believe that Dee Dee's dealings with Abraham were just unscrupulous coincidences and that he was indeed in hiding. Others were certain he had met with foul play but there wasn't sufficient evidence to support an arrest. Everything pertaining to Dee Dee more had been searched. Aside from her efforts to claim Abraham's last million dollars, not a single thing was found to indicate that she had physically harmed him. It wasn't until detectives interviewed Greg Smith and learnt he was in cahoots with Dee Dee that they formulated a plan.
大约在这个时候，迪迪从这个账户中提取了大笔资金，购买了珠宝和几辆高端汽车，并支付了餐费和旅行费用。虽然迪迪表面上是在帮助亚伯拉罕收回他借给别人的钱，但还款实际上直接进了她的口袋。迪迪声称从亚伯拉罕那里买下了他的豪宅，但没有文件证明这一点。当侦探们用这个差异和许多其他差异与她对质时，迪迪用更离奇的解释改变了她的故事。有些人愿意相信迪迪与亚伯拉罕的交易只是不道德的巧合，他确实在躲藏。其他人则确信他遭遇了不测，但没有足够的证据支持逮捕。与迪迪·摩尔有关的一切都已被搜查。除了她试图索取亚伯拉罕最后一百万美元的努力外，没有发现任何迹象表明她对他造成了身体伤害。直到侦探们采访了格雷格·史密斯并得知他与迪迪勾结，他们才制定了一个计划。
We think Dee Dee more does know something they told Greg and we need someone to help us get that information out of her. Greg was then asked to become a confidential informant. It wasn't a decision Greg made lightly but he harboured his own suspicions about Dee Dee. He spoke to Judy Hagins, the other person involved in overseeing Abraham's finances. Judy recalled a time when Dee Dee called her in a panic. Abraham was heading to the bank and Dee Dee needed Judy to stall him. He can't go to the bank, Dee Dee told her. Abraham once confided in Judy, now you know that white woman got me money, she can do anything to me. Greg had a gut feeling Abraham was dead. He told Detective Wallace, I'm in, whatever I got to do, I'm all in.
“我们认为迪迪·摩尔确实知道些什么，”他们告诉格雷格，“我们需要有人帮助我们从她那里获取这些信息。”格雷格随后被要求成为秘密线人。这不是格雷格轻易做出的决定，但他对迪迪有自己的怀疑。他与负责监督亚伯拉罕财务的另一人朱迪·哈金斯谈过。朱迪回忆起迪迪有一次惊慌失措地给她打电话。亚伯拉罕正要去银行，迪迪需要朱迪拖住他。“他不能去银行，”迪迪告诉她。亚伯拉罕曾向朱迪吐露：“现在你知道那个白人女人拿了我的钱，她能对我做任何事。”格雷格有一种直觉，亚伯拉罕已经死了。他告诉华莱士侦探：“我加入，无论我必须做什么，我都全力以赴。”
During their initial meeting Dee Dee launched herself at Greg, suspecting he was wearing a wire. He was able to reassure her. They met multiple times over the following weeks. All the while Greg covertly recorded their conversations. Dee Dee spouted off unbelievable stories non-stop, barely giving Greg a moment's silence. One minute she was sobbing in his arms, the next she'd snap to a composed state and rattle on about a different subject. She seemed to lose herself in her convoluted lies and made up a dangerous drug dealer named Ronald to implicate in Abraham's disappearance. Later she talked about Ronald as if he were a real person. Greg was disturbed. Still, he went along with whatever strange plot Dee Dee devised to hinder the investigation, all the while hoping she'd reveal what really happened to Abraham.
在他们最初的会面中，迪迪扑向格雷格，怀疑他戴着窃听器。他能够让她放心。在接下来的几周里，他们多次见面。在此期间，格雷格秘密录下了他们的谈话。迪迪不停地喷出令人难以置信的故事，几乎没给格雷格留下一刻的沉默。一会儿她在他的怀里啜泣，下一刻她就会恢复冷静，喋喋不休地谈论另一个话题。她似乎迷失在自己错综复杂的谎言中，并编造了一个危险的毒贩罗纳德来牵连亚伯拉罕的失踪。后来她谈论罗纳德就像他是一个真实的人一样。格雷格感到不安。尽管如此，他还是顺从了迪迪为阻碍调查而设计的任何奇怪阴谋，同时希望她能揭示亚伯拉罕到底发生了什么。
When she wrote a bizarre rambling letter to Abraham's mother as Abraham, Greg felt it was completely unconvincing but told her otherwise. After the pair dropped it off in the mailbox, detectives swooped in and took it as evidence. Greg endured a lot in his role as an informant. His local community saw him spending time with Dee Dee and rumors spread. Many suspected the pair had conspired together to get rid of Abraham. It was far from the truth but Greg couldn't defend himself lest he ruin everything he was working for. He couldn't let Dee Dee get away with it. When she started talking about Abraham being dead, the operation kicked up a notch. An undercover police officer was brought in to play Mike Smith, Greg's prison-bound cousin.
当她以亚伯拉罕的名义给亚伯拉罕的母亲写了一封古怪的漫谈信时，格雷格觉得这完全没有说服力，但告诉她并非如此。两人把它放进邮箱后，侦探们迅速出动并将其作为证据。格雷格在作为线人的角色中忍受了很多。他所在的社区看到他与迪迪在一起，谣言四起。许多人怀疑两人合谋除掉了亚伯拉罕。事实远非如此，但格雷格无法为自己辩护，以免毁掉他正在努力的一切。他不能让迪迪逍遥法外。当她开始谈论亚伯拉罕已死时，行动升级了。一名卧底警察被带进来扮演迈克·史密斯，格雷格即将入狱的表弟。
Using Mike as a fall guy, Greg extracted more compelling evidence from Dee Dee, specifically where they would find Abraham's body. The realisation that Abraham had been murdered was heartbreaking for Greg, but he had succeeded in locating his friend. After learning that Greg Smith was a police informant, Dee Dee Moore took a long, deep breath. She then implicated Mike Smith. Learning that he was an undercover detective, she burst into tears and began a long rant blaming drug dealer Ronald for shooting Abraham with her gun. It was no use. Detectives already had audio recordings of Dee Dee fabricating the character of Ronald to Greg Smith. She went on and on about Ronald before a detective cut her off, saying, Dee Dee, Dee Dee, there's no Ronald.
利用迈克作为替罪羊，格雷格从迪迪那里提取了更有力的证据，特别是他们会在哪里找到亚伯拉罕的尸体。意识到亚伯拉罕被谋杀对格雷格来说是令人心碎的，但他成功找到了他的朋友。在得知格雷格·史密斯是警察线人后，迪迪·摩尔深吸了一口气。然后她牵连了迈克·史密斯。得知他是卧底侦探后，她泪流满面，开始长篇大论，指责毒贩罗纳德用她的枪射杀了亚伯拉罕。没用了。侦探们已经有了迪迪向格雷格·史密斯编造罗纳德这个角色的录音。她继续喋喋不休地谈论罗纳德，直到一名侦探打断她，说：“迪迪，迪迪，没有罗纳德。”
She tensed up before telling a new story about a drug deal gone wrong. Dee Dee claimed someone held a gun to her head and she'd passed out from fear. She came too, only to witness Abraham being fatally shot. The detectives asked who the shooter was, but Dee Dee started, saying she couldn't remember. One detective remarked, you can't tell us because it's you and you're scared. Dee Dee's ex-husband revealed that he'd delivered a backhoe to her plant city home in April 2009. He used it to help Dee Dee dig a large hole as she wanted to burn and bury some remodeling debris. She asked him to return hours later to fill the hole with dirt.
她紧张起来，然后讲述了一个关于毒品交易出错的新故事。迪迪声称有人用枪指着她的头，她因恐惧而昏倒了。她醒来时，只目睹了亚伯拉罕被致命枪击。侦探们问谁是枪手，但迪迪开始说她记不起来了。一名侦探评论道：“你不能告诉我们，因为是你，而且你很害怕。”迪迪的前夫透露，他在2009年4月给她的植物城家送了一台挖掘机。他用它帮迪迪挖了一个大洞，因为她想烧掉并掩埋一些改造碎片。她让他几个小时后回来用土填满洞。
A cement contractor poured the slab in Dee Dee's backyard that same month. She told him she wanted a solid slab to park her vehicles on. Eventually, Dee Dee would admit that Abraham's body was buried under the concrete slab in her backyard. Following two days of excavation work, Abraham Shakespeare's remains were uncovered six feet below the slab, nine months after he'd disappeared. He'd sustained two 38 caliber gunshots to the chest, but the bullets were too deteriorated to be compared to Dee Dee's revolver. She continued to give other explanations for Abraham's murder, each more outlandish than the last. She implicated everyone from Abraham's cousin Cedric Adam to his attorney Howard Stitzel. At one point, Dee Dee claimed she and Abraham had fought over money and he'd gripped her throat.
同年那个月，一名水泥承包商在迪迪的后院浇筑了板子。她告诉他，她想要一块坚固的板子来停放她的车辆。最终，迪迪承认亚伯拉罕的尸体被埋在她后院的混凝土板下。经过两天的挖掘工作，亚伯拉罕·莎士比亚的遗体在失踪九个月后在板下六英尺处被发现。他的胸部遭受了两发.38口径的枪击，但子弹损坏严重，无法与迪迪的左轮手枪进行比对。她继续为亚伯拉罕的谋杀给出其他解释，每一个都比上一个更离奇。她牵连了从亚伯拉罕的表弟塞德里克·亚当到他的律师霍华德·斯蒂策尔的所有人。有一次，迪迪声称她和亚伯拉罕为了钱吵架，他掐住了她的喉咙。
As she started to lose consciousness, someone shot Abraham, but she didn't see who. She conceded that it could have been her, but if it was, it was in self-defense. Just when detectives thought they'd heard it all, Dee Dee said her 14-year-old son was responsible. She then tried to convince her ailing, elderly father to confess to the murder. In the eyes of detectives, it was clear that Dee Dee was a habitual and shameless liar. They described her as a professional con artist, a devil in disguise. Dee Dee Moore was charged with the first degree murder of Abraham Shakespeare. Dee Dee's trial commenced in November 2012, six years after Abraham Shakespeare won the lottery.
当她开始失去知觉时，有人射杀了亚伯拉罕，但她没看到是谁。她承认可能是她，但如果是的话，那是出于自卫。就在侦探们以为他们听到了这一切时，迪迪说她14岁的儿子是罪魁祸首。然后她试图说服她生病的老父亲承认谋杀。在侦探们看来，很明显迪迪是一个习惯性的、无耻的骗子。他们形容她是职业骗子，伪装的魔鬼。迪迪·摩尔被控一级谋杀亚伯拉罕·莎士比亚。迪迪的审判于2012年11月开始，距离亚伯拉罕·莎士比亚中彩票已经六年了。
The prosecution posited that Dee Dee had found Abraham's fears of losing his remaining wealth by exaggerating the amount he'd lose to paying child support. Up until that point, Abraham was a good father. Then Dee Dee filled his head with lies about infidelity and the possibility that his youngest child wasn't even his. Abraham took Dee Dee's word that she'd protect his money if he granted her access to it. When he realized he was being scammed, a confrontation ensued. Dee Dee shot Abraham with her revolver before burying his body in her backyard. She then won about creating conflicting rumors and false sightings to hinder the search for Abraham. There was no shortage of witnesses testifying against Dee Dee, including the star witness, Greg Smith, whose covert recordings were played.
检方提出，迪迪通过夸大他支付子女抚养费的损失金额，发现了亚伯拉罕对失去剩余财富的恐惧。在那之前，亚伯拉罕是个好父亲。然后迪迪用关于不忠和最小的孩子甚至不是他亲生的谎言填满了他的头脑。亚伯拉罕相信了迪迪的话，如果他允许她接触他的钱，她会保护他的钱。当他意识到自己被骗时，冲突随之而来。迪迪用她的左轮手枪射杀了亚伯拉罕，然后把他的尸体埋在她的后院。然后她开始制造相互矛盾的谣言和虚假的目击事件来阻碍对亚伯拉罕的搜寻。不乏有证人出庭指证迪迪，包括明星证人格雷格·史密斯，他的秘密录音被播放了。
During court, Dee Dee often broke down in tears, bringing proceedings to a halt. She kept winking, smiling and gesturing to the jury. On one occasion, she apparently went into anaphylactic shock. The judge cautioned the defense attorneys to control their client. She was so disruptive that the judge eventually cut off her microphone. The defense highlighted that the case relied on circumstantial evidence. While they admitted Dee Dee was devious, they argued there was no proof she'd committed murder. Her refusal to provide a clear explanation of Abraham's murder was indicative that her life was in danger and she feared speaking the truth.
在法庭上，迪迪经常泪流满面，导致诉讼中断。她不停地向陪审团眨眼、微笑和做手势。有一次，她显然出现了过敏性休克。法官告诫辩护律师要控制他们的当事人。她太具有破坏性，以至于法官最终切断了她的麦克风。辩方强调，该案依赖于间接证据。虽然他们承认迪迪是狡猾的，但他们辩称没有证据表明她犯了谋杀罪。她拒绝就亚伯拉罕的谋杀提供明确解释，这表明她的生命处于危险之中，她害怕说出真相。
The defense called no witnesses, instead relying on painting the prosecution witnesses as untruthful or unreliable. The jury deliberated for three hours before finding Dee Dee more guilty of the first-degree murder of Abraham Shakespeare. The presiding judge described to Dee Dee as cold, calculated and cruel, saying she was, quote, probably the most manipulative person that this court has seen. Abraham Shakespeare was your prey and your victim. Money was the root of the evil that you brought to Abraham. Abraham's mother Elizabeth was a religious person and fundamentally against the death penalty, so the prosecution didn't push for it. Instead, Dee Dee Moore was sentenced to life in prison without parole.
辩方没有传唤任何证人，而是依靠将检方证人描绘成不诚实或不可靠的人。陪审团审议了三个小时，认定迪迪·摩尔犯有一级谋杀亚伯拉罕·莎士比亚罪。主审法官形容迪迪冷酷、精于算计且残忍，称她是“本法院见过的最善于操纵的人”。亚伯拉罕·莎士比亚是你的猎物和受害者。金钱是你带给亚伯拉罕的邪恶根源。亚伯拉罕的母亲伊丽莎白是一个有宗教信仰的人，从根本上反对死刑，所以检方没有推动死刑。相反，迪迪·摩尔被判处终身监禁，不得假释。
Elizabeth expressed gratitude to the detectives that led the investigation into her son's disappearance, saying, Without their dedication and persistence, we might never have found out what happened to Abraham. During Abraham's memorial service, the large crowd of mourners gave the detectives a standing ovation. Appearing in emotional media interviews from prison, Dee Dee Moore called anyone who believed she was guilty an idiot. She blamed her verdict on her legal team's refusal to let her testify in her own defense. With each new interview came a different version of events pertaining to Abraham's murder. Then, in 2019, Dee Dee Moore appealed her conviction. She apologized for her actions, this time claiming Greg Smith killed Abraham after finding out that he was having an affair with Greg's wife.
伊丽莎白向领导调查她儿子失踪案的侦探们表示感谢，她说：“没有他们的奉献和坚持，我们可能永远不会发现亚伯拉罕发生了什么。”在亚伯拉罕的追悼会上，一大群哀悼者为侦探们起立鼓掌。在狱中接受情绪化的媒体采访时，迪迪·摩尔称任何相信她有罪的人都是白痴。她将自己的判决归咎于她的法律团队拒绝让她为自己的辩护作证。每一次新的采访都带来了关于亚伯拉罕谋杀案的不同版本事件。然后，在2019年，迪迪·摩尔对她的定罪提出上诉。她为自己的行为道歉，这次声称格雷格·史密斯在发现亚伯拉罕与格雷格的妻子有染后杀死了他。
Her appeal was rejected. An investigator involved with the case described these claims as typical of Dee Dee, saying, She'll go down in her grave trying to blame this on somebody else. People have asked me if I think she will ever come clean and I say absolutely not. Dee Dee will die in prison still claiming her innocence. Dee Dee maintains her innocence to this day, yet she also accepts that her ever-changing version of events is confusing, conclusory and vague. Lottery winners are often the target of harassment, solicitations, scams, extortions, burglaries, kidnappings and homicides. Therefore, winners are advised to keep quiet, hire an attorney and remain anonymous.
她的上诉被驳回。参与此案的一名调查员将这些说法描述为迪迪的典型特征，他说：“她会带着试图把这件事归咎于别人的努力进坟墓。人们问我是否认为她会坦白，我说绝对不会。迪迪会死在监狱里，仍然声称自己无罪。”迪迪至今仍坚持自己的清白，但她也承认她不断变化的事件版本是令人困惑、结论性的和模糊的。彩票中奖者经常成为骚扰、索取、诈骗、勒索、入室盗窃、绑架和谋杀的目标。因此，建议中奖者保持安静，聘请律师并保持匿名。
If an individual is legally required to collect their winnings in person, it's common for them to wear a disguise to avoid the publicity. When Abraham Shakespeare won the lottery, regulations in his home state required all winners publicly reveal their name and city of residence. In May 2022, Florida introduced a new law creating a public records exemption for the names of people who win lottery prizes of $250,000 or more. The exemption lasts 90 days from the moment the prize is claimed. This is deemed sufficient time for winners to plan responsibly, obtain financial advice, put their funds into investments or leave their old lives behind. One of the bill's sponsors said, At some point in our lives, we all dream of winning the lottery. Unfortunately for some, that dream becomes a nightmare. In the aftermath of Abraham Shakespeare's murder, only a couple of hundred thousand dollars of his $17 million lottery win were recovered.
如果个人在法律上被要求亲自领取奖金，他们通常会戴上伪装以避免宣传。当亚伯拉罕·莎士比亚中彩票时，他所在州的法规要求所有中奖者公开披露他们的姓名和居住城市。2022年5月，佛罗里达州出台了一项新法律，为赢得25万美元或以上彩票奖金的人的姓名创建了公共记录豁免。豁免期为领取奖金之日起90天。这被认为足以让中奖者负责任地计划、获得财务建议、将资金投入投资或抛弃旧生活。该法案的发起人之一说：“在我们生命中的某个时刻，我们都梦想中彩票。不幸的是，对一些人来说，那个梦想变成了噩梦。”在亚伯拉罕·莎士比亚被谋杀后，他1700万美元彩票奖金中只有几十万美元被追回。
That money was placed in a trust for his sons. At Abraham's mansion on Red Hawk Bend Drive, two welcome mats greeted guests at the front door. One featured the message, bless this home, the other read, go away. Jim Valenti was Abraham's appellate attorney during his civil suit in 2007. At the time, Jim said, Abraham Shakespeare was a man who was very weary by the time he got to me. I wonder if he wouldn't say he would like to go back to the day before he won that money. On a chilly night in 1991, a group of teenagers gathered in their usual hangout, a barren stretch of desert next to a busy highway near Bakersfield, California.
那笔钱被存入了一个为他儿子设立的信托基金中。在亚伯拉罕位于红鹰弯道的豪宅里，两块迎宾垫在正门迎接客人。一块写着“祝福这个家”，另一块写着“走开”。吉姆·瓦伦蒂是亚伯拉罕2007年民事诉讼期间的上诉律师。当时，吉姆说：“亚伯拉罕·莎士比亚在找到我时已经是一个非常疲惫的人了。我不知道他是否会说他想回到中奖前的那一天。”1991年一个寒冷的夜晚，一群青少年聚集在他们通常的聚会地点，那是加利福尼亚州贝克斯菲尔德附近一条繁忙高速公路旁的一片荒凉沙漠。
A dismal spot littered with trash and shell casings. By nightfall, it turned into a sort of lovers lane where high school kids drank and smoked. When two boys left their group and headed into the darkness, they came upon a horrific scene, the body of a young woman murdered just hours before. She had no enemies besides girls at school, teenage stuff, not any kind of trouble that somebody would murder her. This 1991 murder made news headlines for years as it shocked and divided a quiet working class community. Of course, I knew about Maria's case. Everyone in Bakersfield knows about Maria's case. People would just, they would glue to their TV sets and read the paper every day. There was a lot of speculation in Wasco that maybe he was not the all-around athlete that people thought he might be. When he lied about being her boyfriend, I felt like he had something to do with it.
这是一个凄凉的地方，到处都是垃圾和弹壳。到了晚上，它变成了一个情侣约会点，高中生们在这里喝酒抽烟。当两个男孩离开他们的小团体走进黑暗中时，他们撞见了一个可怕的场景：一具年轻女性的尸体，她就在几小时前被谋杀。除了学校里的女生之间那些青春期的琐事，她没有敌人，也没有任何会招致杀身之祸的麻烦。这起1991年的谋杀案多年来一直占据新闻头条，因为它震惊并分裂了一个安静的工人阶级社区。当然，我知道玛丽亚的案子。贝克斯菲尔德的每个人都知道玛丽亚的案子。人们会紧盯着电视，每天阅读报纸。在瓦斯科，人们有很多猜测，认为他可能并不是大家所认为的那种全能运动员。当他撒谎说自己是她男朋友时，我觉得他肯定与此有关。
Justice took its course in a twisted and controversial case that captivated many. But what if the real killer were yet to be discovered? Because he warned me that he told me that I would tell the detective that he was here when he wasn't really here. If you asked the sheriff's department and if you asked the prosecutor's office, they would say, yeah, we solved it. It's just unfortunate how things ended up. In this series, we will hear brand new clues, interview people that have never spoken publicly before, and discover family secrets that shed light on who may have killed Maria Rodriguez and why. I kind of want all of our families, hidden secrets, and all of the dark past. I want it to come out to light. I'm Octavia McHenry for Case File Presents, and this is In the Shadows, the story of Maria Rodriguez. Thanks for watching. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
正义在一个扭曲且充满争议的案件中得到了伸张，该案吸引了许多人的关注。但如果真正的凶手尚未被发现呢？因为他警告过我，他告诉我，我会告诉侦探他当时在这里，而实际上他并不在这里。如果你去问治安官部门和检察官办公室，他们会说，是的，我们破案了。事情的结局只是令人遗憾。在本系列节目中，我们将听到全新的线索，采访从未公开露面的人，并揭开家庭秘密，这些秘密将揭示谁可能杀害了玛丽亚·罗德里格斯以及原因。我希望我们所有家庭隐藏的秘密和所有黑暗的过去都能大白于天下。我是奥克塔维亚·麦克亨利，代表Case File Presents为您报道，这就是《在阴影中》，玛丽亚·罗德里格斯的故事。感谢观看。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。